هو رابع هجوم تشنه روسيا خلال خمسه ايام
على ميناء اوكراني على نهر الدنوب مستخدمه
طائرات مسيره مما الحق ادرانا بصوامع حبوب
وببني تحتيه اخرى وفقا لمسؤولين اوكرانيين
ومنذ انتهاء العمل باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود في تموز
يوليو صعد طرفا النزاع من هجماته ما في
هذه المنطقه موسكو اعلنت من جهتها يوم
الخميس عن اسقاط خمس مسيرات اوكرانيه في
جنوب روسيا وقرب
والعاصمه وفي اطار حرب المسيرات هذه علق
الامين العام لحلف الشمال الاطلسي على
عثور رومانيا على حطام مسيره داخل
[موسيقى]
اراضيها ليس لدينا معلومات تشير الى اي
هجوم روسي متعمد ننتظر نتيجه التحقيق وبغض
النظر عن تلك النتيجه نراقب عن كثب ما
يجري بالقرب من حدودنا كما قمنا بمضاعفه
وجودنا في الجزء الشرقي من
الح في الاثناء تستمر موسكو بالتعبير عن
استيائها وتنديد باعلان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي عن تزويد كاف بذخائر تحتوي على
اليورانيوم
المنضب قرار الولايات المتحده سيء وقد
استخدمت هذه القذائف في يوغسلافيا وادت
الى زياده هائله في عدد المصابين بالسرطان
ستتحمل الاداره الامريكيه المسؤوليه
الكامله
والمباشره ذخائر الوران المنضب قادر على
اختراق المدرعات الثقيله لكنها مثيره
للجدل بسبب المخاطر الصحيه على العسكريين
والسكان